federal agents sent to restore order in
portland
have poured petrol on disorder
what was a largely peaceful protest has
escalated
into violence
the main battle line is here outside the
federal courthouse
protesters unable to pull down the new
fence
throw fireworks over tear gas
is fired back many here are prepared for
this
but as federal agents emerge in their
dozens
those in gas masks run too rubber
bullets
fired into the darkness it's quite
frightening
this isn't the first time tear gas has
been fired at protesters
tonight but it's the first time we've
seen federal agents
outside of the federal courthouse it's
the first time
it's driven crowds away but it doesn't
look like they've gone
certainly it doesn't seem like either
side is going to give up anytime
soon protests have been a nightly ritual
since the killing of george floyd in
minneapolis
over eight weeks ago but crowds have
only grown
since federal troops arrived here now
protesting
their very presence in this city do you
think this violence is undermining your
cause
you know what i don't i don't believe in
violence
at all but unfortunately
you know you got to make noise right i
haven't seen anyone get hurt or killed
here
right i see some fireworks
i see some people making a lot of like
rackets
it's not just residents who want them
gone the city's mayor caught in the tear
gas on wednesday
has called them an occupying force
and homeland security increasingly
resembles a military presence
a video shared last week by one of
oregon's senators
shows a protester being taken by
camouflage
troops in an unmarked vehicle this week
donald trump pledged to send in federal
troops to more
democrat-run cities today i'm announcing
a surge of federal law enforcement into
american
communities plagued by violent crime
the election fast approaching some say
this is about winning votes
meanwhile protesters here prepare for
another night of battle
what's brought you out serving and
protecting
since you know protecting what
my community here from what
federal troops are far from fulfilling
the president's pledge
to restore order